[Music]
which one of the kids is the better
singer I can't because they're gonna
watch this by the way you ordered a dog
the other day Mariah Carey spilling
secrets about dem babies on Jimmy Kimmel
Live as the dog arrived or did you
cancel the dog
apparently seven-year-old rock has a
habit of racking up big bills by online
shopping but will he charge five
thousand dollars on something no he
didn't yeah you did Mariah and Jimmy
also got into her one season stint on
American Idol
I didn't have the world's best fix oh I
think everybody got that what was the
worst part of being a judge in America
I'll tell you the best part with some of
the memes that we got experience we'd
have to go back there but there was a
good hairstyle oh yeah well stick to the
positive okay my hair style let's go
back to yeah of course Jimmy had to ask
me me about ABC's revival of the singing
competition which her pal Lionel Richie
judges is it true that you told him not
to do American Idol when he was thinking
about whether or not he should judge it
if I didn't that should have
[Applause]
[Music]